What's up guys, we're Pongfinity!
Today we're practising with Benedek Olah.
Let's have a good practise!
Come on!
So before you come to the practise
it's important to set your mind already
what you're going to do.
Like you have to know when is your tournament
or when is your next match.
If you play in the weekends,
Mondays you can push it a little bit harder with the footworks.
So today is kind of footwork and strength training
and I like to do some small stuff which I have problems in the match
so I can also correct my mistakes.
But before the practise starts, I know what I'm going to do.
Exersice one.
In this exercise players play backhand topspin against each other
with high speed and whenever Miikka wants to change here
I'll try to catch it with a fast controlled forehand drive.
This excersice is good to develop your reaction speed from the backhand side
and also gives you a steady safe feeling in the backhand.
Remember to keep your racket always up so you can keep up with the speed here.
Exercise two.
Here we have Miikka play forehand loop from the middle for me all over the table.
It's hard excercise for both of you so try to keep up the good quality
and hit as many as you can on the table.
This is also super fun to play!
I can't do anything from that!
Excercise 3: Forehand tactical counter loop.
Here we work on our forehand finishing shot with an optional backhand finish.
We give one side a half-long service, which he opens up to our forehand side
and we work on finishing the point here.
It's important to do this from your match services also
to get used to the spins you get from your own service.
Critical jackpot!
Excercise 4: This is all about small detail spins
and how you continue the game after that.
This is very tactical and various for every person.
Try to picture how people normally return your service
and how you will make a point from that.
Multiball, here we can practise most effectively
because your partner shouldn't miss any balls.
One-two, one-two, one-two.
First one short, one long underspin after that.
Middle middle, backhand backhand, straight lines.
So I flip, and you give me...
Yes!
Then the next one short and one long topspin.
Here we develop the in and out movement.
Your multiball partner will not give you time between the two balls
and you have to move back after the short like your life depends on it!
Change, let's go!
Short long, extremely fast like, one-two.
Important to make the short return with good quality
not just giving a high ball with not so much spin.
You play here or here, tatatatataa.
Excercise two:
Fast tempo balls all over the table.
Faster!
This needs some skill from the coach too because it's so fast.
So you have to keep your hand always up,
otherwise you're going to be late.
It's all about reaction speed and hitting the ball
as quicky as possible without mistakes.
If you miss too many, you should try to put some balls on the table first
before advancing to the higher level and speed.
So idea now is the cross-step.
And the point is when you make the cross-step,
you go forward with it.
So that it's not a defensive one.
Now this will be though on the legs and is also something I'm not so good at.
You try to move to the forehand with one cross-leg-step as far as you can go
and come back from this position and continue the game.
One more you can do it!
Come on put everything there!
Jump, jump!
Otto your turn.
Oh my god!
You should use cross-step when you have to cover a lot of ground
and a single normal step is not enough.
Allright so hope you guys enjoyed seeing
how an olympic table tennis player practises.
Don't forget to subscribe right here, until next time!